hello I wish I was a little bit taller I
wish I was a baller I wish I had a girl
Northwest and Penelope Disick proved
they're the reigning kids of tick tock
dressing their besties up exactly like
them I don't know how you're gonna top
that Kourtney Kardashian's 10 year old
daughter tackled the trend first
transforming her BFF from this to this
yeah and if Penelope's friend looks
familiar that's because it's Selena
Gomez's little sister Gracie who's been
in plenty of tick tocks of her own with
her Superstar sis
foreign
[Music]
who posted this clip of her younger
sister Chicago changing from a Batgirl
costume to Shades a black T-shirt shorts
slides and a crossbody bag
yeah North understood the assignment
because that bit looks a whole lot like
something she would wear her new
favorite thing ever is doing makeovers
and no one can see until the final look
is done of course Kim and Kanye West's
nine-year-old daughter is no stranger to
a good transformation on Tick Tock
You're a mean one
Mr Grinch last month North gave her mom
a grinch makeover just in time for the
holidays putting her makeup skills to
the test she really isn't a beauty and
she loves a little bit of makeup nice
kid and back in April North traded green
for yellow when she gave Kim the minion
treatment
[Music]
and last year the mommy daughter Duo
shared this clip peeling away their epic
DIY special effects makeup
foreign
[Music]
ly it's no secret that North loves to
play with makeup in fact back in 2018
Kim told ET that her daughter was always
getting into her kkw beauty products I
was getting ready today and she was a
little too quiet and I look over and
she's like destroying the palette and
has
just blue eyeshadow all over her entire
face the new kkw Beauty
black eyeliner
oh I actually had to put her on our PR
list and get her her own set of makeup
because she destroys all of mine when
she sees it and then I can't use it for
myself so she she definitely loves
makeup as for Kim's ex and North's dad
Kanye West a source tells E.T they're
legally in a better space since their
divorce was finalized in November the
former couple shares four children
together nine-year-old daughter North
seven-year-old son Saint four-year-old
daughter Chicago and three-year-old son
Saul they'll share joint custody of
their kids with equal access though Kim
will have the kids majority of the time
and when it comes to love
ET Source says Kim will date when she's
ready but for now she's focusing on her
kids who are feeling very supported and
loved by her
[Music]
foreign